oh no
no oh if you look at it
it's diabolical behavior so it's like
the last video skippy so much i figured
i'd give you another one
so uh i just got done with work and
i uh swung by uh to pick up some
groceries
and stop is that a klondike bar
it's a whole rack of klondike bars bro i
swear to god
if he goes into what would you do for a
klondike bar
i swear to god this date is gonna get a
lot better
a lot better i was like i'm not going to
look at these again
ever the same way especially when
she lives three blocks away from where
it is that i buy groceries and so
um to fulfill the having her
try it out uh these are klondike bars uh
specifically these
are uh the original one um it's ice
cream
it's a it's chocolate coated ice cream
no they're not the best because i would
even say their oreo ones are better but
just
having it right here you don't have to
if you don't want to
should we try a uh this is a surprise
visit
yeah no i gave her zero notice in fact
i spent the majority of the day uh
sending her messages
saying i don't get why you don't like me
essentially stuff like that
this is hard man this is hard to watch
this man really showed up at a woman's
house unannounced after she didn't reply
to any of his messages
and he came with some klondike bars and
what's even more offensive after
learning this is that 10 seconds earlier
he's like
you don't have to eat these klondike
bars if you don't want to with me right
now
as if he cares about consent it's going
exactly in the direction i think he's
going
and i really don't like that um
having messaged her like four times
today
do you like me check yes or no
this is what i'm gonna say to y'all
if you guys can make it through this
whole video without quitting
amen please smash the like button this
is crazy and even if you have to quit
before it's done
still smash the like because this is
crazy this man
must be stopped must
be stopped i'm putting out an apb not
because i want to make i do want to make
money off these videos
but also because i want to warn people
about skippy until this man goes to
rehab
ladies protect yourselves okay all right
hands up
at all times that i would bring by the
klondike bar
oh you're having one too right you know
what this feels like this feels like a
hostage situation
where the hostage is like trying to
sympathize with her hostage taker
just to make it out of the situation
alive yeah this is hella awkward yeah he
showed up at her house
unannounced creepy ass
after not responding to the messages
with oh bro i would be worried that
someone would try to take me up
listen bruh i genuinely feel bad for her
oh yeah i'm definitely
uh i'm just uh it's here to
hear i'll hold while you have your
experience
with him oh yeah okay
so how i've been asked in the comments a
couple times
how do you go your entire life without
having tried the conduct part like
someone asked me
are you foreign i'm from earth
so you do read the comments so you do
hear everyone telling you you're
unbelievably creepy and nasty
well every time a girl says no he just
goes over that so why would he
like true bad comments um you can be
from earth and be foreign
america yeah from america i
have i'm sure there are other people who
have never had a klondike no there's
probably some
there's probably some but there's the
whole what would you do for a condom
did you know the jungle i think it's
yeah yeah i've heard it
okay um i suppose you just never thought
i think it's weird if people have never
been to california or people have never
been
and like to the ocean the ocean yeah
like that's weird to me
yeah so i guess maybe this is a thing
that's weird to people
um a couple in the comments
uh but that's okay there's lots of weird
people in the comments lovers i guess
what what what did you say there's a lot
of weird people in the comments
the audacity what what you had the
audacity
you had the audacity
to call people in the comment weird
what what the audacity of carcassity
we have skippy being skipped for various
reasons come on
jack what
what what what what what
what you called them weird weird
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you you
too hashtag you like a rare pokemon that
nobody wants
mew too everybody likes me too but he a
version of mewtwo that nobody wants
pew pew two
feel me yeah it's about to happen
okay okay
all right so wrapped okay cheers cheers
nice
you know what excuse me reminds me of
he's reminds one of those hostage takers
that try to empathize and like there's
nobody who can love you like i can
serena
and that's why you're locked 10 feet
below my basement would you like a
klondike bar let's touch clock night
bars
serena you haven't eaten your food in
three days i just want to go
home to my family i am your family
serena
i texted you four times today and you
didn't respond
why didn't you put a checkpoint beside
it serena how come you've never had a
kolondek bar
serena do you think we make a cute
couple serena i didn't even stare at
your titties aren't i such a gentleman
serena have you ever been with jim
serena serena
serena can i get a kiss serena unlocked
to this better than me serena
i want you to kiss me only if you want
to i want to get out of here i can't do
that
uh the chocolate's not that yummy on it
that's it it's just like those ice
creams that are on a stick with
chocolate and ice cream
is there is there like caramel in it no
it's just ice cream
this is the original funny taste does it
have a funny taste no
no i think it's um how about i describe
it
like there's toffee or something well
that was a little really
it's trying to be more than um
just chocolate tasting right it's like
trying to be
um the ice cream the vanilla is really
creamy
and the chocolate is trying to be
there's nothing written on the package
or anything um about the box does it say
something about it
well there's 12 different flavors yeah
so
the oreo one i almost got you but i'm
like no we gotta have her uh
try the original chocolatey coated
and ice cream loaded
it's artificially flavored vanilla light
ice cream in a milk chocolate flavored
coating
indiana what would you do for a conic
bar
this putting me through this
right what have i done to you gotta make
money
is it worth it yeah
dairy product that was the first concept
oh no no he did not he did not he didn't
do it
oh no he didn't do it he sounded hold up
hold up hold on hold on hold up he's
time to do this right
yeah and then she wasn't looking at him
on purpose no and then he was winning
for a kiss
he lunged hey man no yo
i don't even know how this is still up
on youtube i'm not glad you
oh lord no i can't oh
my god oh no no no man this guy's
actually legitimately have to
he has to be stopped oh no this man
literally has to be stopped oh no
this is live on youtube and i think he's
got ads on this kind of stuff so like
the way that this is monetized is crazy
this is legitimately something that
should be taken off because he's filming
these people
no i can't so he puts money on
assaulting people
on the web cornering people and he is
able to monetize
that but i say certain words
it's a no-no i can't wait to watch this
back and see if your eyes are
terrified as i did that i know i was
reading the box sorry
then i dropped all these bars on the
ground
can we try it for real all right guys we
did it can we try it for real
wow
bro okay shit's giving me anxiety
[Applause]
yeah man i wouldn't be mad if her
brother came by and stomp this dude out
real tough i don't care who stomps this
man out man
wow absolute trash violating people's
boundaries recognizing that they might
be scared but still doing it
and then saying can we try it for now
like you do not care
you don't care you get completely told
that you don't care
i know people make fun of him and think
it's like funny to some degree but this
is legitimately like
absolutely die absolutely diabolical
behavior
can you do the accent if you look at it
it's diabolical behavior
you cannot just go to someone and expect
them
to just behave like that how is you know
what
he's an animal okay i don't know how
people like that are able to
hey hey my friend i can't do it uh for
me it's a big problem
every time i see this one tabernacle
it's causing me
greater take and i think i'm done with
this video
if you endorse this kind of thing you
think it's funny uh you have a problem
but it could be funny but if you don't
think that this is extremely problematic
and should be taken off the web i don't
know what to tell you that's
crazy this man legitimately did that
that's all i got that's all i got i
can't talk about this anymore
if you guys made it to the end thank you
smash like button sub all that good
stuff
but i need a break i need to take some
time off
the internet's a weird place and uh
ladies
you know what i mean every day
sympathize y'all with y'all a little bit
more because this is no
that's a no that's enough and anybody
who accepts go on a date with this dude
without googling him i feel bad for you
as well
so that's all i got no thank you i'm in
my safe place
i'm i'm a snowflake
[Music]
foreign